are we up are we live can you guys see
me
can you guys hear me
says 14 seconds in hi
hi everybody oh my goodness
okay that's an ad i just gave myself an
ad
all right sweet hi everybody this is
crazy um yeah it is my actual
legitimate birthday today and i'm super
excited thank you guys for the uh howdys
and the the hellos and
he looks older live
yeah i feel older live
this is live i'm just an old man
but uh yeah this is awesome it is my it
is my birthday august 22nd i am
a leo
which i take astrology very seriously it
means i am
very bold
generally as a leo when is the joshua
reveal elliot thank you hey
hey my hair looks great
thank you i did nothing to it i slept i
i i that's all i slept
um
joshua's god no joshua not god jake
carrying years larry has made it thank
you
wow we got a hundred people here all
right the hype is real um it is my
birthday when are we cutting the cake um
joshua's hair is better this is this
hurts this is hurting me
in
videos lv videos lv first off you are
a champ and a hero thank you
for the five bucks that's really nice um
how old am i
uh robert e first off robert loyal loyal
to the very end i've seen you around
forever i am 24 today
which um my wife kindly woke me up today
and said
you are officially in your
and that was the kind of existential
dread i experienced happy 50th thank you
yeah i'm 24 going on 50. so write a
biography about joshua
um yeah oh i forgot i can click on
people's stuff yeah i'm going gonna
click on your stuff so we're basically
starting a countdown right now so just
setting this up this is a legitimate
wife reveal this isn't fake this isn't
um
old old yeah yeah thank you for
reminding me yeah this is why i can't do
tick tock um
leo's are kings of i woke up like this
yeah
yeah that's right
so we're starting a countdown let's uh
let's have somebody keep track because i
don't really know how but we're starting
countdown to official wife reveal let's
put it at i don't know
10 minutes five minutes
i know you guys are dying to see the
wife
um
i'm glad you moved on from deborah and
got married yeah i did
i did move on from deborah um
it's a
can marrying thing what yeah so i
married on uh
moved on past deborah obviously still in
legal difficulty
um because joshua is a clumsy boy and
he's uh he's just alive
um
sadly i mean happily he's he's it's
great he's alive he's living and he's
taken me to court
uh gorb gorb is uh one of the best
best humans i assume they are human um
i paused the rhythm of war audiobook for
this better be worth it i cannot promise
you it'll be worth it but i appreciate
the
uh the hype have i read cormac mccarthy
i have read cormac mccarthy i love blood
meridian is really good
um it's really depressing though where's
pazuzu is being kind to me it's my
birthday so they are not haunting me
um
yeah
yeah it's so great to see everybody
um
i mean
all of these i'm sorry you know the
stream's moving fast so i'm trying to
read everything i can but
you know this is just
very kind thank you everyone for the
kind words
and um
crimson cloak says i just got into a
studying mode promised myself i'd study
14 hours straight and get into a
straight routine then procrastinate
again because of this live stream
i'm i'm really sorry i'm really sorry
about that
all right so
at 10
it's it's 10 here in on the pacific
coast in in the wonderful state of
california um it is 1005 at 10 10.
she appears my actual wife
deb i mean nadia her name's nadia not
i i keep calling her debra she's not a
fan
so excited to meet your wife parasocial
yeah
a lot of people doubt that i'm actually
married but you know i
i wear a wedding ring like in every
video so
um that might cue it in uh very real
human
um
uh read mistborn please yeah yeah yeah
yeah
um
yeah deborah
deborah
yeah of course deborah's real so is my
new wife who is a far and improved uh
deborah
it's it's um it's great you know deborah
left me for joshua
and um
you know but but things move up things
things move ahead and uh
uh you move forward and you get happier
in life and you learn to accept this
just the pain and the struggle of life
and you move on
all of the birthday wishes i really
appreciate it this is very nice
happy birthday thank you where's brian
sanders i don't know the restraining
order has yet to be lifted um david
david death he has a wonderful um
channel i did a video collab with him
recently thank you david i appreciate
that um
i think it's more like you left deborah
for nadia you know what
i'll tell i'll tell her that
i will tell her that because who needs
deborah anyways i mean i'm so much
better
off right
um my cat is licking my feet and my
socks are wet this is such this is
guys this is the type of insightful
commentary that i want to be seeing on
stream chat
um i want to see more comments like this
this
is the commentary that needs to be
spoken thank you martin i appreciate
that
how's your day been old man
yeah i'm pretty old
my day has been um great i woke up uh to
existential dread and uh just been
moving on from there
open ah
open
a couple things you're gonna like
from my
amazing mother-in-law sent these to me
huh
that's right
that's where i get my shelf from i don't
you ask my wife
um
and
yeah
that's right
that's right
we are excited we are hype for
more wheel of time
yeah first off
my shelf is like wonderful right because
a certain donald green roasted it
recently which really hurt my feelings
he said that
my books need to be in order and that
they shouldn't all be sideways like this
and you know what happened because we
love our bookshelf and i've always loved
the way i organized it what happened is
my
my wife saw the video and it's been
affecting her psychologically and she's
going now i can't unsee
the bookshelf
so yeah
nadia where
yeah nadia's coming soon hey crazy fan
take i appreciate that ten dollars
that's very really nice thank you happy
birthday crazy fan take been here since
the start what did what a true what a
true hero and um
to all the patrons who are appearing to
say hi and happy birthday i see you
and you are
you are better than
than
human beings are capable of being that's
that's the
expression i'll go with
i am as old as naive at the beginning of
the wheel of time
okay that makes me feel better because i
i feel like naive isn't
i feel good that's that's a good age i
think
goblin supremacy i prefer that to joshua
supremacy
um
yeah this is this is wonderful
why is the stephen king box empty all
right so this
the stephen king box is empty because i
have them stacked out on the shelf
and um
i have them like that until i finish the
dang books and so i have the books i
have yet to finish in one stack and one
on the other so it makes sense all right
don't you know it makes sense donald
green uh no braids to tug though yeah i
definitely need some braids to hug all
right how are we doing on time all right
one minute until the wife revealed the
hype is
is beyond
beyond real are you late no you're not
don't worry about it rick
rick will maybe one day make an
appearance
and it'll be a beautiful amazing thing
turn all the books sideways gorb gorb
don't do that to me don't do that to me
you carry no thing yeah yeah
i know dragon reborn spread i'm super
excited for the dragon reborn um
i feel like it's gonna be
i feel like it's gonna be really good um
yeah
so
are you revealing to some random woman
that she is now your wife
surprisingly no
um
really surprisingly no this is a real
human
person who is my wife
and it's real
and
it's 10 10.
so
oh when am i reading
sangha suzanna i'm reading it right now
i'm halfway through and it's really good
it's so it's
way better than people give it
uh he's 24 going on 50 that's right have
you i read dragon butcher no i haven't
um but i'm i'm going to um i i think
i'll read that
after the wheel of time which i'll
finish the wheel of time in like five
years no i'm just kidding all right
wife time people
it's lifetime so this is very special
nadia has actually
not appeared in any of my videos until
now it's very exciting
and i'm very excited for you to say hi
to her um
and yeah this is my best friend and
person i love more than the universe so
are you ready deborah i mean nadia are
you ready yeah come here
thank you sir
thanks for making me so nervous
oh my god yeah here's the chat yeah
that's right wife
wife yeah how are you doing hon
you know not very excited that you call
me deborah oh it's fun it's fun she
loves it yeah i love it it's she's a fan
of it
hi hello
is the stream quality good yeah it's
good
this is great
oh this moves faster than this oh does
it or slower than this yeah
oh hi nadia you are so much better than
deborah see oh thank you
can you tell him that why does he look
so normal around his wife it's it's a
calming kind of thing yeah i i look
really strange and weird outside of
the marriage but that's why
that's why nadia is in my life she makes
me someone more normal but she's
actually way weirder than me believe it
or not
um
what are your thoughts on jake's legal
yeah what are you thinking about that
um
[Music]
i thought the attorney said i couldn't
talk about it
did you tell did you did you talk about
how i'm related to deborah
no
she's my twin
are you building lore right now
wow
yeah she's um
she yeah i guess deborah is your twin
that's why i married you again i mean
that explains why the photos on the
shelf hasn't changed right
right yeah that's right that's why the
photos haven't changed because they're
twins
and yeah i know gasp she's way better
than deborah i know exactly woman
carrying things yeah we're uh you should
have that channel name you should make
that channel make it make it a woman
caring man
uh what is my least favorite english
word do you know
um
when i tell you
decisive
did did jake hire you nadia how much did
he pay you to come on live you know my
contract says i can't i can't reveal
that don't mention the contract don't do
that
that's not good we don't talk about the
contract
um
joshua two is coming for you
what
oh your camera work is amazing yeah her
camera work is amazing um
yeah because she will honestly on the
videos we do together she will like do
like 50 takes i swear like i will be
i'll be sweating and exhausted and
she'll be like oh one more take one more
take and she's like the stanley kubrick
of booktube related skits
um
i don't believe a word this jake person
says
um
you know what that's that's totally
you're right totally you're right uh
blink twice if you need help
stop it
sorry
i didn't mean to do that that was more
than twice
um
yeah do you guys have any questions for
nadia while she's here um
she's
an amazing person uh oh here you go
what's your what's nadia's favorite book
or series
you know i really like
well the book that i recently really
liked is um the silent patient
silent patient yeah yeah you read that
you really love that yeah i'm trying to
get him to read it too she really likes
thrillers
um yeah i like fantasy too
um well where'd you get that shelf good
question wayfair
way fair yeah that's the name i forget
all the time
um
what
can't say i'm legally obligated
unfortunately ah
yeah yeah you're very oh
thank you
uh do you play any video games
did you remember you bought me mario
yeah for my birthday two years ago i
used to play as a kid and um for this
birthday i want the mario party
like the old school the old school yeah
i like old school but i used to play
zelda
and i kind of want to play it again um
star wars
uh grabbed by the ghoulies i used to
used to any favorite movies
well i kind of been on a repeat of lord
of the rings
i want to watch it like for the 10th
time
she loves lord of the rings and yeah it
makes me watch it way more than and
harry potter but jake is not very i've
seen harry potter so many times yeah
um
let's see there was a question deborah
uh jake or joshua pick now this is nadia
nadia not deborah this is nadia but it's
okay
all right if you had to pick jake or
joshua who would you pick
don't answer that um
where are you from if you want to answer
uh seattle
seattle
um
lord of the rings great taste
i know she is a keeper yeah i mean
that's that's uh we are married so
well i mean i did force you
you know i i did say that i won't
testify against you if you married me
and left deborah for good do you know
again we don't have to get on track we
don't have to get
i mean yeah yeah you're right
he wants to be with me he likes to be
with me that's right um nadia's favorite
music artist
okay
um they're a lot let's see
i think i'm right now it's elvis
[Music]
elvis presley yeah
really
okay
i mean with like the uh the jailhouse
frog and uh what's that one suspicious
minds i
that's our road trip song that's our
that is our rituals yeah yeah totally um
wow we got 250 people watching right now
that is amazing
uh thank you for all of your kind
comments and
um making um deborah i mean nadia feel
welcome it's it's uh you know not nadia
like because you know she's been the one
who was really doing the
the the work you know and i i wouldn't
have started the channel period if it
weren't for her
like legitimately because she um
she uh did
you know everything motivated me to to
make videos because i
and forced me to like at gunpoint sorry
not at gunpoint just mean knife point
yeah and um
forced me to to to make videos when i
didn't want to so there's that um so i'm
very grateful i can't take this guy
seriously
is he ever not trolling i'm confused um
i did not force him over gunpoint i
forced him over knife
a difference it's a big difference i
mean it's a big legal
big legal difference i did say you're
gonna be on your second divorce if you
don't do this so
really
do you not read our contracts how much
can jake bench and what color crocs does
he wear
he can bench
zero
but
he wears a yellow crocs that says
i am the man who carries things
and he lifts water bottles
to prove to me that he can carry things
um
am i the only spanish speaker you
speak spanish right i did study abroad
but i i can't i lost it all i know some
spanish
i can read it and then i'll understand
rick is el jefe
right
he's the boss that's right mm-hmm i know
that word
um
nirvani vibe he's definitely the boss in
your patreon nevani vibes that's really
nice
um
what is your the which okay
one
one liter water okay this is very
interesting
you you guys have some interesting
comments
and
here's a question
oh david yeah thanks nadia for forcing
me to make on it yeah um absolutely yeah
nadia is carrying man carrying thing
that's so true it's so true
here's here's my arms are so sore
um jake blink twice if she's kidnapped
you wait wait what what what what what
what
[Laughter]
i i didn't
hey gorb uh uh nadia can you make your
husband get a cat oh my god i love you
thank you
oh my god you see
i've been wanting a cat since forever
jake is allergic
i had a cat growing up i loved him a lot
he uh his name was jaden
and i love my dogs of course but i'm
kind of dog and cat person i want a cat
so bad i want to rescue one
but jake keeps leaning on his allergy
and he took an allergy test and it's
like two that's barely allergic
thank you gorb for the um for the
donation five dollars very very nice
thank you and um yeah cats uh
cats are great
um i need to i need to watch your live
streams every single time i have people
talk about cats what a gor gorb's been
trying to get me to get a cat for
for years
me too you and i are on the same page
yeah there are hypo allergenic ones yeah
get dog we you know we have dog we have
two we we we're gonna get six more
yeah we live in a small place so i'm
trying to
yeah see um
pop the benadryl pills and get on the
cat train there you go
are you guys really gonna that got me
really excited look at that honey
you guys are bullying me to get a cat on
my own birthday
oh my god
cats are evil
uh says on a scale of four does it don't
read that don't don't read it um i read
it
if you get a cat you will complete your
villain ensemble yeah that's true i like
to have that you can have a video where
you have the cat and you can go like
this every time
you talk about joshua
yeah yeah i i suppose i suppose i could
here's a question for you guys um i mean
joshua would have gotten a cat for me
but that's fine sorry go ahead
i love her that's great
um
hey potato um wish i could stay and hang
out but i'm running errands i believe i
hope you have fun
thank you so much potato for the five
five bucks that's really sweet really um
and you are awesome potato's been around
for for freaking ever and
um
yeah i will have a happy birthday have
fun with your errands
um
okay wow you're being bullied into
getting a cat make your peace with it
thank you
you know what i think i think i will
start a channel and just have the
comments read you know make anything get
a cat just for that
okay thank you so much for the ten
dollars but honestly
no no thank you very much
yeah thanks okay all right what is this
all right
finance the cat honey but it's five
euros so it's it's more u.s
euros are higher in currency
are we really doing a cat fund right now
on my birthday yes
oh my god what was whoa oh my god was
getting fun was telling you guys about
okay i think we're
have say bye to nadia
[Laughter]
on let me let me click
um
cat cat fun thank you
robert oh
is the thing that man carrying thing is
carrying the groceries into the house
for you like a man should and does he do
it all in one trip ah he doesn't do it
all in one trip he does it
you know it's it's really i do it all in
one trip what are you talking about wait
hold on and then like when we go grocery
shopping together he expects me to help
him
that's not a man carrying thing is it
that man expecting is it bad to expect
my wife to help me with the carrying
groceries i mean i mean you wouldn't be
if you weren't mean caring thing but you
know
kind of false advertisement if you don't
do it by yourself
thank you robert i appreciate that um
question that trying trying to like
sidetrack from the cat stuff i
appreciate that
um
um
that that's like an hour long
that's really nice um i
my videos are all like one
one uh
uh one minute long so doing the 17
minute thing i did last time was really
hard um because it takes forever um
okay it turns out that man was carrying
cat all along from toast batman thank
you for the five dollars that's very
sweet toast toast toast
toast batman
and um
but
but i was not carrying a cat all along i
was i have two dogs they're great one is
like a cat one is like a cat yeah that's
what i say uh all the time
so um
yeah we've got uh let's see oh i think i
missed something
what does it say i
go up oh there it is oh i don't know how
much it cost to adopt a hairless cat but
maybe this will help
okay so i love you guys
this is it's like my birthday
it is like your birthday
it's like my birthday yeah hey they say
happy wife happy life right which is
like your birthday is that what they say
yeah
um
yeah that's a great great phrase and um
but thank you david that's really sweet
um but the ten dollars will
be going to my legal battle probably um
have you watched friends episode with
the hairless cat that's what it reminds
me of
do you remember that episode
on friends i remember that episode i've
seen friends i'm a friend's fanatic
uh why get a cat when you have a dog
good question
because why not have it all
am i gonna do more videos like that 17
minute one yeah i mean um i love
reading all of people's comments um who
who's you know submitted to talk about
character deaths um because
it is just content in my ear it's just
like pure content i get to read your
insane and some of you have some really
weird takes um not just weird takes but
like you just want everyone to die
um which you know
it's all good okay oh do you want to
answer this question how did you guys
meet oh man that that's a long story we
met in college you know what we might
have to do a video
yeah because that it's a complicated
thing like we met but it was it was
complicated it was like a four months of
i don't okay i don't want all of my
embarrassing uh horrible flirting to be
revealed quite yet so
or my book thing yeah we won't
we will we'll do a video i think yeah
it's a it's a story for sure yeah we
don't yeah we'll we'll talk about that
um
i love the faulkner video thank you that
you know that's one that people always
um seem to mention i really like it
because that was an early one i did also
um
faulkner is very
special to to me so um
as you know you call him dad every time
you read it you're going to read that
don't tell them that
um
i thank you very much mct thanks to you
i start reading dune the following week
thanks to me that's really awesome um
i'm really happy to hear that dune is a
fantastic read um
have you read gun
no because you don't want me to start on
a later book what
you like hype me up about like the
second book or something oh yeah so this
is what she does the other day
he doesn't let me read it yeah so i get
rhythm of war
and i'm like oh great i can't wait to
read this after a finished earthquake
finnish oathbringer and then noddy is
like you know what i think i want to
read
um i think i want to read the stormid
archive and i'm like great way of kings
is a wonderful read have fun and she
goes no no i want to read rhythm of war
well because i wanted to read at the
same time he read something and i'm a
fan of audiobooks
as well as physical books but he doesn't
like audiobooks i'm like hey i can
listen to audiobooks while you read the
physical book and when you're not
reading the physical no
no
this is about her starting four books
into the stormlight freaking archive
okay can you please
knock some sense into her and tell her
that you can't just start rhythm of war
without reading the earlier books i mean
come on
look at that joshua okay
oh yeah
i mean
you know
i thought i wasn't going to be reminded
yeah it is his birthday honey it's okay
honey it's okay you can still have a
great birthday it's okay you're okay
you're okay it won't i'm just taunting
me he's taunting me joshua's just
freaking tired i won't snitch on you
well guess what joshua i'm using that
ten dollars to pay for my my university
of phoenix online classes okay to
to to be my own lawyer all right and
i'll win i'll beat it all right
you know the good thing is i can take
all of this money when he goes i mean
when he doesn't go to prison
nothing
[ __ ] okay all right we're yeah uh
plans to read expanse books yes
absolutely um
what
what what did you read someone said they
killed their cat what wait wait wait
what i saw it somewhere i swear just
skim past we don't need to see that oh
my god um you can't skip three thousand
pages nadia thank you thank you
uh you know but i like to
i can't say that okay
there's a lot of opinions you can't say
uh it's against genie of the conventions
to read any fantasy series out of order
um
yeah well what's late i have no idea
what's going on this is my
uh irl wife as the gamers like to say
is that what the camera say
i guess yeah that's what this is nadia
say hi to nadia
not deborah
that's my twin start the way of kingside
come on okay first off this would be
fantastic content could you imagine me
you know like having her read way of
kings and then talking about it on the
channel that'd be so fun that's content
i'm down i'm down
you know i have a great video idea for
you what well you read that message
first uh
ari says your content is awesome and
brings so much enjoyment to my life
thank you ari that's really sweet it's
awesome i um
yeah that's very sweet and
uh these comments
and all of your kindness everyone is
really awesome they gave me a great idea
for a video are you ready
you know how you did your last video of
like 17 minutes of just like reading
people's comments yes
what about you do that again but the
topic this time is why you should get a
cat and you try to argue that this has
been great fun
just saying if you can't argue it then
no no that probably means that you
should get it don't worry i'm not going
yet we're gonna go at least for an hour
today because we are
we are you know celebrating
birthday i mean your birthday yeah your
birthday right right the hell
um
i was proselytizing to strangers in the
bookstores they read the way of kings um
yeah absolutely i mean there's really no
excuse for you people not to have read
way of kings yet uh jake if you don't
have chocolate chip pancakes for the
live we will be forced to um
[Music]
i don't tell them
okay
all right she made waffles for me this
morning
yeah i made waffles and i felt bad i
felt like you guys would cancel me if
you saw me eat waffles and not pancakes
because i kind of had that twitter feud
with donald green
um i can't cook
except for guys it's my birthday it's my
birthday
remember thank you
it is i mean you know it's it's really
my birthday yeah you know her birthday's
in november how about we do a stream for
that too
uh sure as long as we can discuss the
pros and cons of getting cat more pros
and cons sure
sure sure waffles are great
larry larry has opinions yeah wonderful
larry
um
um jake i got the first three books of
real time for you yesterday
unfortunately i can't send them to you
so i'll just keep
you know i've been telling him to get a
p.o box in all seriousness this week so
um
yeah i i do would you guys want to see a
p.o box uh if i started that
um
let me know i will continue answering
comments but yeah let me know if a po
box would be a good idea um
um let's see
ari thank you again holy cow um what
radian order are you do you think
there's a quiz and brand of site by the
way actually fun story i did that video
probably last year and i never released
it because i was like
i don't know if this is a good idea but
um i
think i was i don't i think i was
shalon's order i think i'm a light
weaver i think i don't have to take it
again i don't really know and then you
should take it to you that'd be
interesting yeah
yeah i'm definitely not um one of those
um order order people you know what i
mean
um all right i gotta i gotta move on
um
pros and cons of getting a cat cat
can i receive live animals in a p.o box
actually
we can ask
i prefer not i don't want cats so bad
cats are great reading partners yes dogs
are not the best reading partners they
like get up in your business uh well not
if you sit on the couch
yeah p.o box that's fantastic um
on a scale of one to nick cage how much
does he move around in his sleeve
oh my god
nick cage being like
the worst end
nic cage yeah
do i i'm not that bad
you are when it's you're always hot
and you
don't like
you don't you always move around and you
go to the floor he sleeps on the floor
because the bed is too hot and then
leaving the bed i sleep with with her
and two other dogs all right so
sometimes i'm like it's so freaking hot
i have to go to the other dogs and 10
other cats
it's okay we don't have to talk about it
light weaver gang
light weaver gang that's right that's
right that's right light weaver yeah i
think i'm still a light weaver um
donald green would send a yeah probably
honestly that's kind of what i would
definitely do those kinds of videos
because one of my favorite things that
daniel green sorry donald gray did on
his channel was exactly that just the um
uh please dear god don't be a bomb and
he stopped for a while because of covet
but um i'm so happy that it's back
because those are the stuffy people send
him it's just so hilarious um
like um jake will get a captain p.o box
yeah okay for real though don't don't no
um
i think you missed one did i miss one
yeah right there okay uh pay the dog tax
the irs demands it show the dog
um what
thank you for the two two euros um
that we have to pay all already like uh
dogs are expensive so just be aware if
you're thinking of getting a dog um
but
i encourage it
dog reveal uh you guys have seen my dogs
right
um
we can all agree that he is
come on
come on
i'll take it um i i agree with that yeah
well i hope so i mean you know josh i
mean no no yeah just you just you just
you're right
uh do i mumble about chocolate cake and
or yeah he mumbles about cookies
chocolate chip cookies yeah guys it's my
birthday i'm gonna pig out like that's
what i do on my birthday i'm just going
to eat so much
krispy kremes
yeah also where it's it's la we're going
out gonna gonna live
life
by going to the bookstore
what time is the pazuzu reveal
yeah
um
i'm
there's a camera i think it has to be a
night time right
he doesn't haunt me except at night
thankfully so i'm good for now don't get
a lot of sleep these days uh cats are
done by a kid all right not helping not
helping solve i disagree about cats but
i do think we should get a camel too
you want to just start a farm
totally down
no she's not joking like she will like
she's uh i i
i love animals um
keep carrying the man
keep carrying thing man thank you ice
cream cartel oh keep carrying thing man
i i i'm forced to it's it's on the
contract you know but yes i mean i want
to i totally want to thank you hey what
is zazar do what is this r do you know
what that currency is
uh no
we'll figure it out
um
how long have you guys been married well
you wanna tell them
a year and a half
that's right yep
we got married during cold bed yeah
that's right we decided to get married
two hours before we got married
it was longer it was a little longer
well yeah it was longer than that but we
got married in this very
well not here in the back on the balcony
it was very romantic my brother mary
does that's right
um
have i ever listened to king gizzard and
the lizard wizard they have lots of
fancy sci-fi things in their lyrics and
are 10 out of 10. no i have never heard
of them um thanks for the uh five bucks
and uh i'll look them up honey
yeah it's okay i can screenshot it yeah
screenshot that king gizzard and the
lizard
i feel like you're trolling me i feel
like you're just trying to like make fun
of me and make me look something up but
i will i'll look it up to see if it's
real um got to sleep uh happy birthday
jake and i you two are great oh that's
very sweet that's really sweet um i
would have never guessed you were la
people really
i honestly have been telling him trying
to persuade him to move to seattle but
the rain is a little too much for him
he's an arizona boy yeah i'm from
arizona so um yeah maybe
we did throw off the lore a little bit
by being uh
it's all good well we got this this is
an alternate timeline just so you know
so it's not really like it didn't throw
off the lure at all because this is
their live streams are always an
alternate timeline so it's like the
marvel movies you know where there's
loki who's dead there's loki who's alive
there's a loki who's in a spoilers
it's like that
uh where's debra who needs deborah
deborah is my twin and she's not in
prison right now by me she's not in a
box somewhere but you know there are so
many weddings in the background yeah
exactly we um we decided like you know
what we didn't want to wait we were just
like
20 20. let's do it um
um
so your wife isn't daniel green
no
no what
when does that ever come about
uh donald green is my father
you have a lot of fathers you know what
i that's what happens when you when when
you have my issues ask my therapist it's
fine
um does my mom know that you scream at
people on the internet
your mother-in-law definitely does yeah
my mom does to um i my a lot of my close
family did not know about the channel
until very recently um so then i think
somebody found a video and that's how
they found out so
um yeah it's been it's been fun uh yeah
seattle represented it isn't very rainy
okay stop reppin seattle all right we're
in la la's great
and seattle's expensive too right not
like l.a ah it's
expensive uh king gizzard is awesome
yeah
um
what um
i only turn into pazuzu at night duh and
it's dinner time now so please leave me
out of this oh and happy birthday man
you're a delight to watch thank you
thank you that's very nice you also turn
into pazuzu at night
i resent that
um
yeah yeah so king gizzard is real that's
cool um here's a question guys if you
could see any kind of video uh from us
uh and maybe because i i don't know i'd
love to make videos with nadia if she's
willing to but um if you want to see her
read
anything what would it be
if you want them if they're going to
pressure me into getting a cat with you
i want them to pressure you into reading
something so
so what what should that be
um
[Music]
yeah i like the rhythm of war
you're not going to start she's not
going to read rhythm of war right away
okay no way i would thank you
way of kings
the wheel of time all right wheel of
time maybe would you read the wheel of
time
um
really enjoyed that last video thank you
that was a
that was a fun video to make i think the
reason why is because i watch his videos
and i already know the spoilers
yeah so kind of reading it it's kind of
already know what's going on you know
so i vicariously feel like i'm reading
it that's true she watches my videos uh
a ton um
i'm i'm uh i'm obsessed
yeah i mean she watched she's very
supportive
it's very very sweet
um how old am i william i am 24
today
um
50 honey
i'm one nothing you're 24 here you're
24. yeah let's keep it at the 24.
um
way of kings miss born yeah yeah love
from india love india um
wow what a great couple jimmy
you flatter us
you flatter us and uh mazza booked hey
don't worry that you're late because
time is is not linear time is just uh
it's a different timeline
different timelines here yeah timelines
yeah
um
malazan i haven't even read malazan yet
ice cream um i yeah i haven't but but
maybe we could read that together maybe
i could read it before you
that'd be great yeah exactly beat me to
the punch
uh start a new series yeah
yeah maybe you could
we could uh tackle all the series out
there maybe you could read uh you know
what first law i really like christina
dodds i don't know if anyone here reads
her but
christina dodds oh yeah i want to read
some of the books that you love
absolutely uh song of ice and fire but
yeah i i need to read a song of ice and
fire i i really want to but it does seem
like the
like the hype is
elsewhere at the moment you know
but i i do really want to uh read it uh
did i read did i buy no i haven't gotten
billy summers but um i'm i am looking
forward to reading that actually i'm
thinking
uh because i love halloween and i do uh
hhn and everything so i i'm going to
read it probably
uh this october we'll see either it or
the stand
i think this is you see something yeah i
have a question is joshua's return
somehow related to alternate timeline
weirdness it's okay if you have to
raffle this uh i think you should make a
video about different timelines
read and find out we didn't find out
head canon
um
uh you guys should read the blade itself
yeah i really i think you'd like it
um
yeah i'm down
yeah it is your favorite book yeah uh
favorite stephen king book um
i like
oh
i like misery
misery's good yeah and especially like
watching the film of it
he's just such a good writer yeah i like
his short stories we have like the
bizarre of bad dreams bad dreams yeah
and i like that too yeah my favorite is
probably uh
the
third dark tower book wastelands yeah um
yeah thoughts on moa do you have any
thoughts on melash
can't say the word but you know you you
know how you know how we feel about him
yeah
um daniel needs to make a deep dive into
the mct universe the universe is getting
really large surprisingly
um and it's getting a bit unwieldy and
it's marvel it's like marvel and it's
all because i made that one video that
um was just me thinking it'd be funny if
i was divorced and uh you know my family
left me because that's what he was
reading he was trying to like emulate
his best fantasy
you know he was tired of hearing about
cats that day and he's just like oh i
can't take any more and then he just
made the video
uh favorite stormlight is words of
radiance um
badly need a stephen king ranking video
yeah you know i want to read more
stephen king before i do that though but
i'll do a ranking dark tower um books
just like i'll do ranking wheel of time
uh when i finish them
uh i thought joshua's dad was joe
anaconda
that might make that might work that
might make sense
um
love to molash ps happy birthday nod oh
thank you
honey i want a cat for my birthday have
you have you looked at different rescue
organizations for me
i mean i could also give you like a link
and i can set up an interview you know i
can do the work i really don't mind you
know i'm really generous with those
things so if you want me to buy myself a
birthday gift for us you know thank you
for the two dollars comic works with
jimmy very nice um
yeah that's awesome
hell yeah
um
uh what are your thoughts about being
obligated to read some books for example
malzahan is good series but i couldn't
uh manage through the first few chapters
but i will love wheel of time um
i don't really read what i feel
obligated to read um if something i kind
of have an idea before i start something
if i like it or not so i don't really
feel like there's a ton of a pressure
you know like wheel of time i didn't
make i didn't make the announcement i
was going to read the whole series until
i read the first half of the first book
and i was like oh this is great i want
to read the whole series then i made
that video so i'm not gonna
i'll read what i i want to read there is
some pressure to like read certain
things like i there's more pressure to
continue on the wheel of time than there
is to read uh dark tower but i really
want to finish dark tower so it's you
kind of have to balance things but but
yeah i don't read anything that is just
like i i would hate to read because i i
do that enough in getting my english
degree you know
um
cats are pazuzu's minions tread lightly
man yeah
um absolutely
so um what's up christian bale
doppelganger do you think i look like
christian bale
i think you can yeah when you have like
um your beard it just you know he his
face structure it changes every time
like depending on his facial hair so he
he can be like 10 other people you know
i mean sometimes he even looks like josh
i mean looks like himself
so anyway
oh thank you jera wizard i appreciate
that um
dark tower uh i love the dark tower it's
one of my favorite series uh ever for
sure and the sixth book uh people give
it hate but i think it's fantastic i
really do
uh what's my favorite oh favorite books
we read in college
oh man
um
[Music]
so i already graduated i graduated two
years that had a female i graduated so
it's kind of a blur but you know what
it's this is a this is an interesting
take um
i didn't think i was going to like
canterbury tales
and then i had a great professor i know
and i had a great professor and i really
liked it so that was the most surprising
thing that i read that i liked
um
i liked
i like that poem
i can't say the word
but do you remember when we met with the
class that we took together
and
i can't i have no idea what you're
talking about
never mind
um
just finished with kings for the first
time and halfway through warbreaker
because of my reading order yes thank
you computer love and thanks for the
five dollars yeah
um that was a fun video to make um i got
legitimately drunk and uh filmed it and
i yeah
that's that's kind of what happened and
um
i don't know i want to do a reading
order for like dark tower soon one of
those videos and um obviously we'll have
time when i finish it so i just i want
to finish wheel of time because i feel
there's so many video ideas i have that
i don't really want to do so bad yeah um
it's a great book
hey let's see did i read the witcher
series no
um
but i
definitely want to
uh wait you're in college i thought you
were 35 i'm i'm so i see people asking
me for my age i'm 70. he's 50.
she's older um yeah i'm like 90 years
older
you know what math
as an english major 20 years older than
me she is 70 years old yeah and i'm 50.
and we
are
just living life
and uh doing that
um
look like christian bale right now okay
christian slater i'll take it i'll buy
it jake is actually gary oldman you know
what
that's fine uh what'd you guys do in
college what did we do i mean i'm still
in college so i just sit in my pajamas
on zoom right now i go to
should i say i've said it i go to ucla
and nadia went to ucla we both met in
community college los angeles city
college
great school um and then we transferred
and so
we are both english majors and that's
how we met we were in an english well
i'm i'm explaining the whole story right
now i said i wasn't going to do this i'm
sorry
we'll do a separate video any if there's
any kind of videos you want to see that
us to make like
like uh how we met that sort of thing uh
let us know because um i i want i want
to know
i do think that we should make a video
about like
letting them know about
how deborah is related to me
because i i see deborah a lot mentioned
and i should clarify about
us being twins but you know we are twins
yeah yeah they're twins but he didn't
marry me because i look like her
you know i
so yeah yeah um we got oh there's a
goblin in here oh wow you want to read
that all jokes aside i just want to say
jake and
your
jake you're great and your wife seems
delightful i just hope when the zombie
apocalypse comes you two have each
other's backs like will you both kill
for food um i will have his back if he
gets me a cat sure
thank you donald ivan daniel
donald daniel
thank you sir that is very kind and i
appreciate that
um again i'm sorry about the bloody
shovel i asked you to hide uh won't
happen again
absolutely not and um
you know zombie apocalypse i would
we're both veg i'm vegetarian nadia's
vegan so um i would kill some crazy
plants for you
yeah i'll kill you for food
i mean no i'll i won't do that it's not
right can't do that can't say that you
would kill me like you'd for for real
kill me
um
no
that's i'm moving along
um goblin sense tingling
oh okay all right all right what what
all right goblin has arrived yeah that's
right that's right that's right and he
wants me to get a cat he's pressuring me
and it's it's it's it's evil it's not
right it's not right um you know if i
booked an interview just just just just
to see different cute cats you know just
just do that would that be a great
birthday gift i mean birthday gifts are
supposed to be a surprise you know so i
don't i shouldn't be asking your
opinions really right we love moash we
love oh
thanks honey i don't know i i'm sorry i
said we love him that's
something i should not be saying
somebody clipped that i on reddit
somebody uh clipped that and
somebody clicked that on reddit and of
me saying i love moash over and over and
it really uh messed with my brain for a
while
and um this is cat money use this to buy
a cat of you
oh my god i need to appear on your live
streams more this is literally my
birthday gift i mean your birthday gift
honey it's okay it's okay you love the
cat
she's taking over the channel
thank you uh
thank you daniel thank you
we love to see it um
and uh cats are you know they're little
devils uh except for pigs which is cool
cats are great they are amazing
i'm on board
could you imagine it's pips too yeah
that'd be so weird um wait
oh okay
um how could i possibly love naive
um
oh no i love naive she's she's awesome
she's hilarious honestly
um
but i can't explain it i just feel like
i i get a a sense
naive is just wonderful
um
you'd like naive i think
well yeah i think so
okay get a cat named him oh my gosh oh
seriously
that's the name of that let's come here
what that's what we had it's the name of
the billy bumbler and uh the dark tower
oh oh
god yeah yeah liking naive is a sign of
understanding what it means to care for
others and being a parental figure yeah
see that's a good way to that's a really
good way to put it uh
naive is is incredibly
i don't know i i feel like i've i've
heard comments from people say like when
they read the book when they were in
middle school they they hated my name
but then when they were older and you
know became parents they're like oh yeah
they really understand naive and i
kind of get that sense i mean oh did you
see that kids
yeah
i like that comment a lot
you wouldn't do that to me no you're not
going to jail i'm not testifying against
you
what's the facial comments
uh-huh yeah just all the facial
expressions um
that's
that's um yeah naive is definitely great
um
my dog and minecraft go down a little
my dog in minecraft is called away yeah
that's great that's wonderful
um oh we got another man carrying things
evil opposite daniel greene
do you think that's holds true
um sorry i just was thinking about
joshua uh saying that again god damn it
um
i guess i'm evil in a way i mean
yeah
i mean serious talk you're pretty evil
when you wake up without coughing
no i'm really not i'm really normal when
i wake up
it's really it's really great when i
wake up and i'm very nice when i wake up
and i'm not cranky at all honey it's
okay drink it drink it
i almost shoved in your mouth i'm sorry
that'd be content though i mean content
content live streams can't be used in
court because once they're over it's not
live therefore it's dead
dead streams can't be used in court oh
my god that mean i can actually like
tell them the truth about joshua no no
sorry
joshua's just a clumsy boy okay
and you want to say he's a clumsy boy
he's a he's he's a he's a clown what
what was it he's a clumsy boy he's a
clumsy boy he did not get pushed he did
not you did not try to get your ex-wife
back and you don't keep calling me
deborah on accident especially obviously
never called you deborah ever it's just
always no of course yeah right i i don't
i don't go to therapy just to have my
self-esteem you know um yeah me and
daniel should do a drunk stream i don't
know if that's um uh sustainable if i
feel like that would be a little
too chaotic what was that video that
there is where like people drink and
then they try to summarize the movie
do you know what i'm talking about yeah
yeah yeah yeah or like drunk history
yeah drunk history oh my god i love
drunk i wanted to do that for um the way
of kings for a while where i try to
summarize the way of kings but um
i never did while i'm drunk
um
it's also hard for you to be drunk
is it
i don't know anymore
but why it used to be
you know really hard it used to be hard
to get me drunk
oh i just you know it was never even
playing field i felt like yeah i haven't
read king killer but uh i guess that
does if i don't like it that would make
me evil as well
um
yeah
oh
it's really nice to watch this channel
woman carrying things
oh thank you
yeah why don't you just take over the
stream i'm gonna go um
i'm gonna go like
i don't know
uh gotta bounce seriously keep doing you
you'll be full time at this in no time
oh that's i i concur that's very sweet
thanks thank you man and
take care
and um
keep reading
um what and keep telling him that he
should get a cat no
every time
um
daniel but
all right is he gone
is he gone i think he is okay i think
daniel left for real though guys i need
to tell you like
what's really like what's really going
on with daniel green
um he helped me kill joshua
he hit the shovel he helped me kill
joshua
um
you know by outing him you're also
adding yourself
nothing happened he's a he's a wonderful
amazing person right and um is actually
very um
i cool you just outed yourself but
woman carrying thing a possibility
is it a possibility i think people want
you to make a channel i don't know they
they want they want the booktube content
from nadia she's a natural addict i'm
really awkward
she's not i'm the awkward one
it's so not true
i mean you should see me at um any
social function ever
all booktubers must have a cat
you know what
um i don't i don't think that's true i
think that's true okay what did you just
see
this is cat toy money
[Laughter]
all right if you don't use it for cat
toys and getting rid of evidence by
feeding the body
what did i just say
honey
so we have like a cat fund now
apparently um
which there goes your other argument
this is lovely yeah and i thought he
left so i said all the dirty secrets
about donald green and then he's still
here apparently but it looks like the
coast is clear i think the coast is
clear i think he's gone i think that was
the last thing he said
so basically
i'm going to tell you guys what is
really down with daniel green remember
you out him you out yourself no no i'm
not outing myself okay he killed joshua
no no no no
no you're not a good testament i go to
the university of phoenix online i know
how to be a lawyer um
he killed joshua okay um i didn't even
have to ask him
he just saw him and fury lit up his eyes
and he honey honey honey it's okay you
wanna drink coffee what's up yeah yeah
can you read the chat please
he just needs coffee
oh look honey woman carrying thing could
be a cat tube channel
that'd be nice yeah
so i would have to get a cat
you don't need a cat to do cat tube
honestly i don't you just said that
would be nice
it would like hypothetically like going
to the moon would be nice you know
i like this one
nadia coop
you don't trust me you don't
you know what if you want to make the
memes please go right ahead
oh my god i would love to see those
um lose all your subscribers
oh my god
no no that would that would definitely
make the channel better
oh joanna canada
you know what he does to people who mess
with him
joe anaconda is is is i'm not scared of
any joanna khan i'm not scared of
anybody um like that all right he's
uh you know who i'm scared of is uh john
r r
or matt matt
martin
john john r martin
scary guy it's funny if he's in men men
she knows she knows what's funnier
um
what is that
what is that
um
my three favorite books yeah let's hear
it
okay so they change because a lot of i'm
i'm a binge reader
so i don't read like slowly like he does
he expands his reading over weeks and he
like bounces around different books no
no no i like to read one and i get
obsessed with it and then i don't sleep
or eat and i think about it and i dream
about it and then i finish it and then i
feel like uh post-book depression
so the recent ones are
what i already said the silent patient
into the darkest corner
um
and
see
it's it's
it's the one that i'm reading but like
you know what something i read the guest
list i like that one too oh yeah i got
that forever yeah so
that's good yeah absolutely and it will
change as i read more because i
i get obsessed with books and she's
going to read the way of kings because
you guys are forcing her right just like
you're forcing me to get accepted
[Music]
yeah this is wonderful coffee or tea i
drink coffee she drinks tea
kinda well she got off coffee because uh
it's it's like bad for you and makes you
jittery i drink probably i drink way
more coffee than i should but i also
don't sleep much at all these days
because i don't know if you guys know
this but when i make videos i basically
uh stay up the entire night so uh
sometimes i'll get an idea for a video
at like 3 a.m and then i'll film it and
then start editing it at like four and
then post it to seven yeah and that's
kind of my work schedule which is very
unhealthy
um so i need to get but you're you just
can't like you don't just can't think of
ideas during daytime
um yeah i can't i can't
i just can't focus on anything in the
daytime he has to he's the most
productive at nighttime
yeah i i really am it's kind of weird uh
you should read frasier yeah frasier
great show from the 90s i love kelsey
grammer um so i should check out the
book series of frasier frasier
see what i did there yeah i thought yep
uh-huh it's funny it's oh my god honey
it's hilarious because it says farcier
and i said frasier
you're you're hilarious honey you're so
funny
um i saw i thought i saw a comment
yes you should okay all right you should
just read rhythm of war and do it for
the memes and then i can i can record
you talking about it and be like why is
everyone like this why is everyone
flying i mean like one of your other
books with the mom your mom reads yeah
yeah yeah and then oh thank you and you
sorry
then you can be like why is calendar
depressed i have no idea
um and i'll be like yeah he went through
a lot in a book you haven't read
woman carrying stream that's right uh
favorite western uh butcher's crossing
hands down for book western favorite
movie western
is my darling clementine she does she
hates westerns no i like darling
clementine though have you seen it yes
we watched it together
my god i don't think she's seen it we
watched it together
oh my god
you always are we will watch something
together and he'll be like you haven't
seen that i'm like you were literally
right next to me while i watched it
it's okay
funniest guy on youtube
huh
yeah
validation yeah can you say i'm the
funniest guy on youtube you're the
funniest guy on
on what
on youtube on youtube yeah right right
right on youtube on youtube uh-huh
thank you kelsey grammer is great as
fitz yeah i really thought so nadia are
you are you in the discord i don't have
a discord but i want to create one yeah
she should get in the discord yeah yeah
um that would be great first off people
who are here if you aren't on the
discord what are you doing what are you
thinking you're missing out on the
discord i need to be on the patreon too
right
patreon i do i do updates book updates
on the patreon i talk about um what i'm
reading more regularly on the patreon so
and do polls sometimes
um seriously on serious note i'm so
thankful about how much you're
supporting him and
he's super talented and amazing and
just
is joshua watching still yeah okay he is
the love of my life and i am
very very thankful for all your support
and
all your
everything that you're doing and how
amazing you are with him and it it
really makes me happy to see him live
out his passion and do things that he
loves and
really really really thank you for that
that was very sweet
oh i saw joshua i mean i i didn't say
any of that i i didn't i you were just i
was i was doing this the whole time so
yeah probably yeah i was uh that's good
save good i was not i did not you might
have been sincere that would have been
terrible
yeah i was not i'm not sincere
oh this is so sweet uh yeah
yeah that's it it would be sweet if it
was sincere but you know
um
way of way of kings narrated by nadia
that would be great
doesn't she have a great voice she keeps
telling me she she doesn't have she has
such a beautiful voice
um
favorite sauce
uh louisiana hot sauce for me you like
honey mustard
yeah joe joel joel haver yeah joe labor
might have been joel haber is freaking
hilarious i love joel haver i commented
on his recent video and he hearted it
he hearted my comment joel haver
hardened my comment yeah i think all
right all right it's okay i'm just
saying yeah he's he knows i exist
yes he knows me okay it's okay honey
joel haver collab
incoming
joel haber is going to be on the channel
okay uh-huh
it's okay all right
oh oh all right
um i was going to bully you for cat even
more but this was too sweet psych
imagine being sincere though
you almost got me there i thought you
were being sincere but you weren't and
you got me
and thank you for that totally ironic
money that you sent me that's very kind
and definitely
going towards the cat
honey honey you know i'm here right you
can't really like you know i can keep
track
now that i'm here now that you've asked
me to join your live stream just a girl
said beautiful voice oh that's right
thank you that's sweet yeah
um joel haver
staying at my house yeah joel havers
he's crashing on the couch um
uh nadia is still screw nick cage you
would be perfect still that's right
you'd be great
um
cheering me up like so
um
and
what books are you reading nowadays
well you're reading right now you're
you went back to doc tower right
what you want i thought you oh oh oh
the maidens right yeah i'm reading the
maidens right now yeah
i i want to read that too as well
um how i feel when i get hearted by jake
uh you know i love um
hearting all the comments and um doing
that because
i feel like
i feel like i don't want to be stingy
with the hearts you know and i try to
heart as many as i can and i definitely
read all the comments that come and it's
getting a little harder because a lot of
people uh
are commenting and i love it but um i do
spend like a dedicated amount of time
all the time to um
do that so yeah um i love reading the
comments that's probably the best but
like my favorite part about doing
booktube is the comments honestly
because you guys are
pretty funny honestly and will like um
just say the weirdest stuff like one of
my favorite
commenters has been commenting every day
for 50 days straight saying uh
commenting until jacob's back with
deborah right what
did i miss that you missed what who's
what's that name what's that name what
do you think i'm not gonna tell them
don't worry deborah where is it what
you're meant to go back i married you
and deborah is way out of the picture
did you hear that i probably heard okay
you're about to get on your second
divorce
[Laughter]
and um
and um
another person does uh uh stand related
comments until i read the stand that's
just like write poetry it's crazy
it's crazy
yeah
suffering from success too many comments
yeah she literally says that every day
i'm like i gotta sit down and comment
all these and she's like wow you poor
child you poor baby
um i don't say it like that you do
you're like oh you poor
person you gotta you you poor terrible
sad person you gotta reply to all these
comments that are nice to you
so i heard i saw something saying about
mustache of if i miss your mustache and
yes i do do you miss my mustache for
real
yeah i think she that's the thing i
people are like oh i feel bad for your
wife you gotta deal with that mustache
and i'm like she wanted me to have the
mustache she was sad when i shaved like
when i clean shaved like she hated it
well like i just think that a lot of
people there are a few who can pull off
mustache and i think he's one of them
she isn't deborah
can you block people in here no i
shouldn't say that i i can i can totally
block people i can send um
you know you know
you know
i hear about deborah enough when he's
sleeping i don't need to hear about her
when he's awake you know
yeah i i go to enough therapy to
convince myself that i'm delusional when
he here says
deborah you used to be so nice he used
to be a great cook nadia can't cook
nadia
is just you know
trying to read rhythm of war like what's
wrong with her before she reads way of
kings like why do i have to deal with
that all because you left me deborah
that's what you say i get to hear this
all all day every day
it's wonderful
it is i mean it's like what is this what
is this lore creation it's incredible
um um yeah yeah oh sorry will i be uh
insta are we gonna make an insta we can
make it insta i think you should make an
ins i already have an instagram insta
what's up uh i have a twitter you guys
should follow me on twitter if you
aren't because that's where i got re i
got retweeted by brandon sanderson on
twitter do you guys know about this did
you hear it did i tell you honey honey
it's okay the the stephen king
interrupts the brandon sanderson
interview that got that got retweeted by
brandon sanderson
brandon sanderson retweeted it or his
account his people did you can't believe
that this is what we're doing on we're
changing the world on this channel we're
getting retweeted by brandon on this
channel this is what's happened this is
howard this is how we change the world
one day at a time
this is genuinely the most effective
world building ever done by mankind
wow
that's um yeah
thank you so much and you know what
happy birthday thank you i feel like
this has been an incredibly successful
stream how do you feel about it i feel
good about it thank you for having me on
in all seriousness
i am so
so so lucky
um joshua's left right do you see joshua
joshua's gone on the chat we don't have
to worry about him okay so i feel really
lucky to
be married to this awesome guy and
to be with him and
he is seriously the most amazing person
ever and
you know i think that the world should
bow down to you i believe in
dictatorship no i shouldn't say that
never mind i shouldn't say that let's
keep politics out of this yeah um
anyway uh
i i'm really happy thank you for having
me on and i'm so it makes me honestly
really happy that jake is supported in
such an amazing way and he has such an
amazing fan base and you guys are
amazing and
so thankful for that so thank you for
thank you for
doing that so
i don't think
anyone could have said it better and
thank you honey thank you for um
appearing on stream clearly
way more popular than me to the channel
they want you to take over and create a
coup so they just like cats honey they
like cats they like you and you know
what there probably will be more
you know what more nadia content to come
right let's let's do it thank you for
all the happy birthday wishes and for
those of you who
who
donated stuff it's really sweet um i'm
flabbergasted that so many people have
been watching it's
awesome it's seriously awesome and um
yeah thank you everybody so we're gonna
go because like it's my birthday and i
love talking can i say one thing really
quickly i just remember like when you
first started youtube and how
we were like you would have
maybe a person comment here and there
and
just to see how
like
you should just really be proud of
yourself and
really you're such an amazing
talented person and
you know really the funniest person
alive i'm so glad i've been paying you
to say this it's really honey you don't
have to say that part okay okay go ahead
but if this is i i'm really proud of
this guy and he you know
i just the biggest thing that icons that
jake has about himself is he doesn't
believe in himself as much as he should
and i'm really really happy that he has
such an amazing team who believes in him
as much as i do so thank you guys so
much i really really
really appreciate it and i'm really
happy that he is living out his dreams
and passions
thank you that's very sweet now you can
pay me afterwards i will pay you jared
i'll i'll give that to nadia for that
yeah i owe you a lot all the compliments
it really you know
it's a lot uh of money out of the pocket
but it's very nice to hear it really
validates me oh look it's my birthday i
mean drinks
um yeah happy birthday to nadia
yes it's nadia's birthday
and we're going to go eat
going to a restaurant
and um
and getting krispy kremes oh yeah we're
going to krispy kreme
yeah um
um yeah so thank you everybody
cuties
oh that's us that's us yeah me separate
alone i'm just like weird to divorce dad
energy but when we're together we are
sorry can you read this really quickly
before we have to go what does it say
can you read it
i i love you all thank you so much for
coming
and take care this has been an
enlightening stream to say the least and
um yeah thank you all it's nice to to
hear or not here but see all your
comments on uh on the birthday so
have a good one
and
thank you all so much
thank you all so much
but doorbell's ring it's so chaos all
right so i gotta go bye everybody